while it isn't stated outright black
panther wakanda forever heavily implies
that imbaku gained a high ranking
position in the African nation the actor
who plays him all but confirmed it
wakanda undergoes a lot of changes
during black panther wakanda forever
this movie is so much the film begins
with the death of King t'challa who was
played by the late Chadwick Boseman
imbaku becomes an advisor to the
wakandan royal family helping shuri as
she creeps t'challa and shuri's mother
Queen Ramona takes the throne after a
fight in Boston that leads to shuri
being kidnapped Ramona takes away
okoye's title as general of the Dora
melange claiming that Okoye is failing
in her role as protector Queen Ramona is
then killed when talocon attacks wakanda
with a flood as shuri struggles with the
sudden deaths of her brother and mother
she decides to step into the suit to the
Black Panther becoming the ultimate
protector of wakanda it's a lot to pack
into two hours and 41 minutes but the
movie still has room for more story
lines as the film continues to add depth
to the characters established in 2018's
Black Panther several new characters
also enter the fold that includes MIT
student and future ironheart Riri
Williams and Namor who rules over
talocon by the end of the movie it seems
that shuri is now the official leader of
wakanda but Winston Duke who plays in
Baku begs to differ
may be the New Black Panther but Duke
has confirmed that imbaku is in fact the
new king of wakanda he recently told
Esquire yeah it's kind of cool though
being revealed as the king of wakanda at
the end of the movie imaku was first
introduced in Black Panther as the
leader of the Jabari tribe he challenges
t'challa for the throne of wakanda
following the death of t'challa's father
tachaka I
mbaku
leader of the Jabari with I accept your
challenge t'challa who had already taken
on the role of black panther years
earlier defeats in Baku replacing his
father as king there is a callback to
this Duel at the end of black panther
wakanda forever the ceremony to make
shuri queen of wakanda has begun but
sure he isn't here she has decided to
visit Nakia and Haiti or sure he meets
her nephew Nakia and t'challa's son when
shuri doesn't arrive at Warrior Falls
the title of King instead appears to be
upper embaku to claim but no visible
Challengers jury's absence at the
ceremony could be interpreted as a
forfeit making imbaku the new king of
wakanda regardless Duke called the
moment huge saying whatever that entails
that's going to be a fun one so what
does it take to be king of wakanda
according to Winston Duke it's all about
putting the people first he told Esquire
I think any power of authority and
Leadership is going to be defined by
their willingness to think of the
greater good for everyone instead of
their own personal needs and agendas
Duke noted that there are still plenty
more stories to tell in this part of the
MCU of course that could include his
potential reign in wakanda said he would
love to see at least four more movies in
the Black Panther Saga he also brought
up the idea of a possible spin-off for
his character and the Jabari tribe he
said they are an entity unto themselves
in the mountains and I feel like if you
got a spin-off and we get to learn what
things mean and why and why they're
special and dive into that culture it
would be something really special